I've spent over a hundred hours studying
the habits of some of the most brilliant
and rich copywriters on the planet. And
in this video, I'm going to break down
five not so obvious habits that almost
every single one of them have. Stick
around cuz number four may shock you. By
the way, I'm Alan Drau. I've sold over
$2 million with my copywriting and I
have over 10,000 followers across my
socials and emails. Copywriting is what
I do all day long. Now, first let me get
the obvious things out of the way in
this video. I'm not going to tell you
things like they work out, they read a
ton of copy, they write for 5 hours a
day. Like, we get it. We know they
probably read a bunch of books, write a
bunch of copy, uh, exercise, like all
the normal stuff. Like, that's not what
I'm trying to tell you in this video.
I'm showing you the not so obvious
things that you may not know unless you
have talked to them, studied them, and
had them tell you from their mouth what
they're doing, which I've done. I've
spent a lot of time buying products from
people like John Carlton, Daniel
Thrasel, Gary Benga, Chris Orzacowski,
Ben Settle, Paris Lampropolis, and a
bunch of other very rich and brilliant
copywriters. That's what I'm going to
break down here. Starting with number
one. Number one is they talk to their
market every single day. By their
market, I'm talking about people that
they sell to. I was talking to the
industry titan, Brian Kurtz, who has
worked with every freaking copywriter on
the planet. He's managed over $9 billion
in direct response advertising. And he
personally told me this story about
Paris laws. Paris is one of the best
copywriters alive and one of his core
markets is actually elderly people in
retirement homes and hospitals. He sells
medications and health supplements and
things like that. And Paris every day
would spend time at these retirement
homes and hospitals talking to the
people that he was selling to. He would
get to know them, have conversations,
understand their stories, and spend
hours hanging out with his market. In
other parallels, like Eugene Schwarz
would read magazines like the National
Inquir and Vogue and all this junk
magazines, he would also go and see the
most popular movies that he didn't even
like because he was trying to get in the
head of what his market was watching and
buying and understanding. or people like
myself, Daniel Thrasell and Ben Settle
who send a daily email and get a flood
of responses for from our market and we
reply and talk to them every day to
understand what problems do they have,
what are they experiencing, what have
they tried. Talking to your market is a
core habit of being a rich and brilliant
copywriter. Habit number two is they
have Avengers. Everybody thinks these
copywriters are single superheroes like
Batman and Superman, Iron Man,
Spider-Man, all these guys. But when in
reality, being a copywriter looks more
like the Justice League and Avengers.
It's coming together with a very small
group of highly talented people. I
myself and am in a very small, tight
text message group with five other
brilliant copywriters. And when I've
talked to those brilliant copywriters,
they've let me know about other
brilliant copywriters that are also in
very tight-knit small groups. I learned
a lot of this while listening to Gary
Halpert tapes with John Carlton. They
would get in small writer rooms and they
would bounce ideas off each other. This
was all on like a 9hour lost tapes from
Gary Halpert that he never released and
he was telling the stories about writing
together with some of his closest
friends and they would challenge each
other and rip each other apart. also
reading books from David Garfingle and
David Deutsch who are known as some of
the greatest copywriting coaches alive.
They do it in tight small groups of very
smart people. Which tells me if you want
to be brilliant, you don't go alone, you
go with people. Habit number three is
they have an alternate obsession. Gary
Benga is obsessed with olive oil. Gary
Halpert was obsessed with riding his
boat. John Carlton is obsessed with
playing golf. Daniel Thorell is obsessed
with his fitness. And Eugene Schwarz was
obsessed with arts and painting and
collecting. Every single brilliant
copywriter that I have come across has
had an alternate obsession to their
copywriting obsession. They've let their
curiosities get the best of the things
that they want to build. And they've
expanded far beyond the copywriting
world to understand what's interesting,
what's worth writing about. And they've
even used these alternative obsessions
to actually take a break from their work
and just enjoy their life, which
ironically makes them better writers.
And number four, this may or may not
shock you, but the most brilliant and
rich copywriters are overwhelmingly
analog. What I mean by that is pen and
paper, mechanical watches. A lot of them
rarely have any social profiles or
social presence at all. And I'm not just
talking about the 80s and '90s people
where social media and the internet
wasn't even a thing. I'm talking about
modern, brilliant, and rich copywriters
as well. Because at first, I thought it
was just a traditional approach. but a
modern approach. People like Ben Settle,
Daniel Thrasell, Chris Orzowski, these
guys live overwhelmingly analog lives in
a very digital world, including myself.
I use mostly pen and paper, wear a
normal watch, I write offline, I record
my videos offline. I'm heavily on social
media, but but maybe if I wasn't, my
hypothesis is that the offline thinking
helps them write better. Obviously, no
distractions, no social media feed, no
really bad, terrible writing content
that you consume. It's a content
curation of really high quality stuff.
Which leads to habit number five is they
write in the dark. In his farewell
seminar, Gary Benoa told the story about
how he would wake up every single day at
6:00 a.m., pour himself a cup of coffee,
and he wouldn't do anything in the world
until he wrote for 3 hours. He wouldn't
look at his phone. He wouldn't answer
his messages. He wouldn't open his mail.
He wouldn't kiss his wife. He'd sit his
butt in the chair and he would write for
three hours in the dark before anybody
was up. Parallel that to a modern
millionaire like Dan Co, who has made
$10 million from his writing while
studying his habits. He recently
released a video talking about his
2-hour morning routine where he goes for
a walk for 30 minutes, writes for 90
minutes, and then opens himself up to
the world. The most brilliant thinkers,
writers, and entrepreneurs in the world
are writing the first thing without
distraction in the dark before they talk
to any human ever. So to recap, habit
number one is they talk to their market
every single day. Habit number two, they
have avengers. Habit number three, they
have an alternative obsession. Habit
number four, they are overwhelmingly
analog. And habit number five is they
write in the dark. I hope you found
these helpful. and honestly give them a
shot in your own routine. I've been
trying stuff like this on and off for
years. I'm very interested on how high
performing copywriters think, function,
and get rich. If you found this video
helpful, do me a favor. Go ahead and hit
the like button on the video and
subscribe to the channel. It tells me
you want me to do more research and make
more incredible content for you to be a
successful copywriter. Also, before you
go, heads up. I've got a bunch of really
cool free stuff for you on my website
allandragu.com/
stuff. I have copywriting catalyst 63
cashcow copywriting secrets, a complete
guide that you can get instantly. I've
also got hook templates, my bestselling
book, meaningful marketing. I have a
video on how to outreach to clients and
get more clients. All kinds of stuff on
there. Head to my website, put your
email in, grab whatever you want, and
enjoy. Thanks for watching. I appreciate
it and I'll catch you on the next